[Musique]
je trouve que le niveau de la
compétition est bon je suis assez
surpris du niveau technique notamment
j'ai pas vu deux
j'ai pas vu dans les matchs que j'ai que
j'ai observé de choses extravagantes
qui comme j'ai pu en observer parfois
certains premier tour de coupe d'afrique
des nations et j'ai l'impression que le
niveau moyen est en hausse je constate
qu'il n'y a plus de petites équipes
qui ont pratiquement le même niveau
cela se justifie au niveau des scores
qu'on enregistre en dehors de l'image du
cameroun et la tunisie on a eu des
scores assez élevé mais sinon saison
d'espoir éthique et 2 0 2 000 marins
bonne qualité des joueurs et je suis
impressionné par certains des joueurs
locaux aussi parfois on pense que les
niveaux de foot africaines des jeux qui
joue en afrique c'est pas trop top mais
en fait je pense que beaucoup de gens
sont assez impressionné avec ce qu'ils
ont vu là et tous les matches sont
serrés comme plusieurs entraîneurs ont
déjà mentionné lors des conférences de
presse les voilà lé score de 3 0 4 050
c'est fini tout ça donc les équipes
gagnent très difficilement et c'est ce
qui donne un charme à cette calme
le cameron ethiopie
bien qu'elle ait camerounais a gagné 4,4
et l'ethiopie à jouer parce que dans son
équipe il ya quels locaux alors que les
camerounais sont tous les professionnels
il venait l'europe est bon les caméras
jubiler mais moi je félicité l'équipe
indiscutablement le match le plus
marquant c'est celui de l'algérie parce
que c'est vraiment un choc pour tout le
football continental l'algérie arrive
ici avec l'étiquette de naturel de
favori numéro un personne n'imagine
qu'elle puisse tomber contre la guinée
équatoriale et c'est même pas un match
nul
une défaite et ça veut pas dire que
l'algérie n'ira pas au bout si ça se
trouve elle ira au bout mais en tout cas
ça a été un petit séisme j'ai vu
quelques matchs je suis pratiquement
tous les matchs du maroc mais le match
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est celui de la
tunisie contre le mali avec ce qui s'est
passé
côté arbitrages parce que c'était une
scène inédite quand même de voir un
arbitre sifflait la fin du match avant
le temps réglementaire ce conte ce qu'on
voit rarement pratiquement jamais donc
c'est ce qui a fait quand même un petit
scandale
si pour cette coupe d'afrique match nul
contre le ghana le gabon parce que tu
avais beaucoup de choses dans ce match
il y avait il y avait de beaux buts il
avait le bon de compétition c'était un
match tactique établie aussi le story
lines avant le match avec pm cab a remis
juste avant le match qui peut pas jouer
il apprend que pas joué à cause du test
car dieu car dieu cardiaque et puis tu
avais à la fin de match un peu le drame
et et on n'aime pas voir leur même pas
voir le violence comme ça mais on aime
voir le patient on me voit comment ça
c'est important pour les gens
de mauvaise surprise c'est justement
cette endémie à kovy 19 cette pandémie a
fait que le la caf et les cas du
cameroun prenait justement il mesure ne
soit
imposée était assez restrictif ce qui
fait que bien des premiers matches on a
vu les gradins vides bon heureusement il
ya eu déjà n'est ce pas cette correction
et c'est peut-être la bonne chose dont
je vais parler on ne voit le retour du
public dans les gradins et on vit
maintenant les matches comme on devrait
les vivres pour une canne au cameroun
nouvelle surprise et c'est patronne
suprise mais le fait comme le match à 14
heures parce que ici au cameroun on est
prêt d'un couteau alors anna des
chaleurs et mons on a l'humilité et mons
je pense que entre les matchs de même
contre les matchs de 17h et le match de
vente il ya une différence de 5 ou 6
degrés alors entre 14h et 20h c'est un
homme le défend ce que ça peut avoir
même sur les athlètes de haut niveau et
on a vu le sénégal par exemple qui ont
joué deux fois les matches à quatre aux
as et c'est vraiment difficile pour sa
2ème année de deux poules et c'est que
qui pied de s'exprimer bien je pense
dans ces conditions très difficiles la
mauvaise surprise pour moi c'est la
pelouse de douala
on s'attendait on nous avait promis on
nous avait vendu des pelouse pour une
fois à la hauteur d'une compétition
continentale
alors il y a
du mieux c'est vrai mais il y à douala
et quand on voit l'état de cette pelouse
c'est un peu inquiétant pour la suite de
la compétition la bonne surprise c'est
vincent aboubakar on sait qu'en club sa
carrière a évolué vers des niveaux qui
font que on ne l'attendait pas forcément
à ce niveau de compétitivité en équipe
nationale cinq buts après trois matches
et puis une grande activité une grande
détermination un leadership évident sur
le terrain je pense qu'il a scotché tout
le monde sur ce début de compétition
vincent aboubakar l'avancé prise demain
je me répète un peu mais je dirais les
prestations quand la vue des jeux qui
joue en afrique et aussi sévèrement
certains le gardien mohamed camara dos
et à l'épaule par exemple qu'ils
arrêtent l'algérie match puis arrêté le
penalty de frank assez de milan dans le
deuxième match
mais attendent beaucoup des résulats
compétition c'est que d'abord un que
reyes pas le faire comme le fait un pli
ça c'est la première des choses c'est la
loi du foot du sport que tout le monde
accepte le résultat est maintenant que
le meilleur gagne et que au niveau des
habitués qui est moins d'erreurs
maintenant que les camerounais ont pris
les les dispositions concernant
l'affluence dans les stades ça laisse
augurer vraiment de trouver les belles
belles ambiances et la passion des
camerounais que l'on nous avait promis
dans les stades et c'est vraiment ce que
j'attends de la suite de ceux de ce
tournoi et je pense que oui on a une
belle compétition on va avoir les chocs
on va avoir des matches qui sont très
compétitives oui j'ai très hâte ce qui
vient